you look at that shot i'm going from the
computer to the floor and i remember we
were running out of time
and i i went down to the floor and i
kept hitting my face
kept bam hitting my face and the take
didn't
didn't work and we were running out of
time we had a lot we had to do
so i went up to stunt guys and i said
give me you know coins here in england
they have
pound coins so i put pound coins in and
i hung
on the on the cables to see was i level
and i had to make it you know and so i
said okay i said
brian's like one more and i'm going to
cut into it and do it and i said
i can do it you know it was also very
physical like straining i'm doing it
so i went down started the computer went
all the way down and a
beautiful set like de palma's amazing
taste went down on the floor
and i didn't touch and i remember i was
there i was like oh my gosh i didn't
touch
and i was holding it holding it holding
it holding it i'm sweating and i'm
sweating
and then he just keeps rolling i just
realized
brian is like he's he's doing it
he is like he is working it it's like we
did it we did it we did it i'm like i am
not gonna stop
and i just hear him off camera and i
could he's got a very distinct laugh and
a very
you know when he laughs and makes me
laugh and he just i could just hear him
start to howl
and he goes all right
[Music]
you